Double toilet for lovers that love to do
everything together no thank you get out
of here with this are you kidding me can
you imagine taking a with your wife
or girlfriend like what I love Rachel
and I'm always Furious when she goes to
the bathroom and leaves the door open I
don't care what she doing in there if
you sitting down the door should be
closed that's between you and your lord
close the door I would not want to sit
next to her she would be all like I'm
holding my hand she wants me to make
everything she does Disney princess even
taking a stinky dump I would have to be
like oh baby he's so cute over there
stinking up the bathroom and I'm not at
the point where I'm in there taking a
poop with the door open I ain't there
yet sitting on the toilet and actually
pooping you're like Okay can somebody
see you but when it's time for cleanup I
need to clean up on my own I need to
clean up with the door closed you ain't
watching me clean up so I would not want
to sit next to my wife during some
cleanup that's crazy
[Music]